on the streets of New Delhi Sarah P
Shrivastav is on a mission
she's asking young women like herself to
stop and think about their sexual health
therapy herself was forced to reckon
with the issue when she went to a
gynecologist to ask for contraceptive
called an intrauterine device or IUD the
gynecologist asked her if she already
had children and if her husband was with
her when should be told the doctor that
she was unmarried she was turned away
she outright denied it and she said that
no it's not safe for you and when I
asked for evidence to prove that she
didn't really have anything to say so I
think again it was very driven by
societal attitudes around who can get an
IUD who is supposed to use contraception
who should be having sex is should we
having sex after being denied by another
doctor so he gave up but she doesn't
want other women too when it comes to
women's health in India authorities are
focused on improving health care for
mothers but a group of young women have
come together to say that their access
to sexual health should not be denied
simply because they're unmarried
they're calling the campaign health over
stigma sex before marriage
look commonly discussed in popular
culture and social media is still a
taboo in India and this often shows in
the attitudes of doctors the campaign is
appealing to medical authorities
hospitals and doctors to sign their code
of conduct and provide non-judgmental
services to all women equally as an
unmarried woman if I go up to the doctor
the doctor shouldn't ask me questions
like are you married or you know like
like do your parents know you know like
things like that so when they go to the
doctor so my confidentiality should be
maintained like I should've been scared
to go to the doctor and the campaign is
resonating with some we live in a
society where where our sexuality is
somehow very much repressed and also
suppressed so I think it is high time
when time to come direct face to face
and have a dialogue about how sexuality
has a role in our lives
sexual hygiene and sexual or matters are
something which are being hidden meaning
that they are not much spoken out stuff
that many people are resistant talking
about these things I think these issues
must be of you know taken up
already Delhi's Medical Council has
agreed to hear the troops petition as
more women join the movement they are
hopeful they can change attitudes across
the country